ho voluto farlo mezzo esperimento perché
è da un po che volevo fare un blog misto
di clip di cose che mi sono successe
negli ultimi tipo mesi
l'altro giorno mi sono messo a
ricapitolare tutto quello che ho
registrato a corpo avuto in un video
solo accorpato complimenti lorenzo ci
sono momenti nella mia vita
secondo me vanno a documentati per i
posteri della serie non siete ecco come
erano gli esseri umani
tempo fa non siate così buona visione
[Musica]
anche la luce della stanza toni che si
accende al comando bellissimo la
situazione dal buon giampiero
dimenticato le chiavi della macchina
dove lei vi dimenticate già a berlino un
po tipo siracusano cia la chiave di
scorta per entrare in macchina che però
apre solo il bagagliaio e quindi deve
entrare ma sei sicuro ha sì quello
labbra poi fai a entrata all in è
impossibile poi bello ordinato una prova
non può impossibile ma io sono io so
amici così comunque entra in macchina ho
visto delle cose non vedenti
ti prego però ad avviare latino fa paura
non si avvia la macchina potrei chiedere
l'aiuto del pubblico
aspettavamo bene
aspetta un secondo se fai questa cosa
qua e continua a farle rispettare un
attimo disse ilo fallito sette volte
all'esame della patente perché i ragazzi
e purtroppo la macchina l'abbiamo
utilizzata adesso dobbiamo fare delle
compere e dobbiamo chiuderla quindi
dobbiamo fare lo stesso procedimento
chiuso ok
[Musica]
o magari degli amici la mia amicizia me
le scelgo bene l'abbiamo vieni vieni dai
anche la mano anche la faccio e fede si
è comprato la nuova lamborghini non
esageriamo diciamo romantici cassettino
ma io avevo volete clientela camera
signora costanza pagate manca ancora
vivo beh a quel paziente questa
relazione è no
questa mamma piace ti voglio senza amore
affetto ricevuto un pochettino troppo
agitato il tutto
tavola mangiando
immagino che poi il ragazzo ci dobbiamo
accontentare un proprio modo si chiedeva
che la cena e giri non modo piacevole e
torino insomma va bene quel che finisce
bene
c'è una società assolutamente quindi lo
stesso ea mi sembra che non si può
concludere in modo video in auge possa
riprendere l'acqua
semplicemente ha recuperato c'è un po di
papà di lorenzo per umano vale ragazzi
allora adesso vi devo preparare per
questa bomba incredibile visto che ci
sto lavorando da mesi è giusto che io
vela introduca nel modo migliore quindi
colonna sonora di harry potter grazie e
non ci arrivo qua aspetta non ci arriva
che fastidio
[Musica]
vabbè poi è finta volevo mettere un
effetto transizione che entri però è
fatto di lei
signori questa è la mia non si capisce
la grandezza proprio farvi capire questo
è un mio dito quindi e ge gigante e ge
hogwards gigante per fare questa croata
di lego ci ho messo quattro mesi più o
meno e non l'ho fatta neanche da solo
l'ho fatta con un mio amico con jean ci
abbiamo impiegato veramente dei secoli
per fine uscita è uscito quanto vedete
adesso cerco di tirarla via dagli così
vi faccio vedere bene come fatta spero
di non scassare tutto per sicurezza
continua a riprendere perché se scasso
tutto mi mi ammazzo però allo stesso
tempo almeno uscito un video che fa
ridere ma allora ragazzi sono circa
6mila pezzi in totale un casino per
farla breve ho messo una vita avevo
fatto un video del degli ultimi istanti
abbiamo messo l'ultimo pezzo di lego per
completarla ma ho cancellato per sbaglio
il video comunque la volevo far vedere
lo stesso perché merita la vita
c'è veramente qualsiasi parte del cast
c'è anche il drago attaccato è veramente
di una figata assurda e ci sono anche
gli interni quindi volendo poi cenare e
pranzare con tutti i quali c'è anche
l'effetto di luci che quello è il sole
il sole non era compresa nella scatola e
quello vero ci sono le scale all'interno
che si muovono e girano ci sono le cose
più che esistano ad hogwarts
praticamente all'interno ci sono anche
addirittura c'è la camera dei segreti
c'è veramente qualsiasi cosa nel mondo
di harry potter all'interno di yogurt
c'è qua dentro anche tipo le stanze
l'aula di pozioni tutte le ragazzine lì
è il mio prof c'è la scacchiera c'è
questo che mi pare sia l'ufficiale la
bridge
c'è tutto quanto di più figo ci possa
essere e mi rendo conto che questo video
può sembrare un placement della lego e
vi giuro che non lo è per il semplice
fatto che io sono un fan di quelli che
si tratterebbe la faccia di daniel
radcliffe al posto della sua ci ho messo
quattro mesi quindi unite le due cose
sono orgoglioso di questo la parte che
mi ha divertito di meno fare è stata
questa ovviamente che sarebbe tipo la la
casa di hagrid che è tutto figo se non
fosse
per questo ce lo dovevamo mettere per
forza ragno baba beh però a parte questo
è veramente figo
dopodiché c'è anche il platano
picchiatore che si muove
e in tutto questo la macchinina dei two
is ii che ovviamente ha fatto una fine
peggiore di quella del film lo hanno
capito chi fossero fino alla fine poi ho
capito che sono i fondatori delle varie
casate di hogwarts tra cui salazar
serpeverde che sembra babbo natale che
lato però vabbè lasciamo per ragazzi
sono veramente orgoglioso di tutto
questo non avrei mai pensato di
raggiungere questo livello di qualità
nella mia vita
costruire hogwards però quanto pare ci
sono riuscito la rimonta prima di far
casino
dopo farvela vedere in un video almeno
in un video dovevo farla vedere e quindi
ragazzi questa era la mia è motivo di
vanto della mia di chiunque entra in
casa mia e vede quella roba lì c'é un
uomo ma anche tu hai un cervello allora
ho scoperto anche io da poco sono molto
orgoglioso di me stesso e quindi erano
le clip che avevo il telefono è sparsa
in giro che l'ho messo insieme la so
contento di aver fatto questo video meno
non vanno sprecati questi momenti capito
come solito ragazzi servito è piaciuto
dare un momento mi piace anche vari
social che come tutte le descrizioni se
non sia per i siti iscrivetevi e ne come
sempre ci dividiamo ragazzi
[Musica]